kommt das war anfang sagen kann also um
sie ist es alles andere als ruhig
geworden
wir sind gegenteil nur sie selbst die
sehenden ruhiger geworden also so aus
also statt fans heißt es jetzt yoga und
statt
die kst familien t was man alles an zu
schreiben aber gelingt jedoch auch oder
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht dass grüner
tee oder oder die partie wie so was
fragst du denn jetzt also trinken also
was ich gelesen habe dass ihr so wie
tief das ist falsch meine of it and
drink 1 t
die lügen die lügen alle die presse lügt
kein thema ist damit aber ich meine wahl
über tiere also ich meine das ist
interessant wenn immer da steht sie
trinken so viel tee der weiters ist das
schreiben aber ich werde dieses werde
ich dann sah ich war ich trinke ich sage
immer was anderes
ach so in ihrem alter sprechen also
nicht um den sohn aber das ist ja im
apfeltee später wahrscheinlich eine
größere rolle nicht meinem alter wie
soll denn da geht doch die verdauung das
geht ja gar nicht mehr so lebst
sie bringen keinen appetit kommt lasst
uns jetzt mal wirklich also dann
ziemlich scheiße
nein nein also ich glaub schon seit 20
jahren uhr tee man ihr müsst mal was
neues
das hieße das sind alles ach das ist
doch was ist es doch völlig
uninteressant ob ich oder jeden tag oder
jeden tag eine flasche whiskey sour wien
geht das was ich fragte was zu trinken
ja also ich meine sie sind wir also wir
jetzt anfangen weil ich muss weg als
prominenter müsste ich noch ein bisschen
gefallen das neue überreden
das sind schon wieder hin dass mit das
ist ein super was sind das für
festgefahren und die nase wieder als sie
müssen als musik ich muss das sind doch
die gesetze der medien ich meine das
machen aber jetzt ein interview
aber nicht so wie du wirst eine wie ich
will
was mich interessiert mich wirklich
jetzt glauben sie mir doch mal dass mich
das interessiert aber aber das ist ihnen
jetzt geht es wieder aufwärts
sie haben gesagt wir haben aufbauen wir
setzen da bin ich einfach ich bin jetzt
wunderbar mir geht's prima aber ich muss
ja auch noch meine ich mache manchmal
ich meinem 12
fange endlich an du machst mich irre
du siehst du wie ich bin ich bin nicht
so wie die anderen also jetzt weiß aber
ich würde so gerne mal nach den rücken
was willst du macht nach dem dritten
zähnen und prostata ich meine probleme
die man hat in ihrer herde problem ich
habe keine probleme damit nicht wir
haben keine ich kann auch eine kleben
also ich meine ich habe jetzt die
schnauze fragt ich will niemand verkehr
also jetzt die fragen fünf minuten
dauern denn ende über verkehr der gut
also autos
ja ja welche autos sie ist ganz anders
darüber autos ja wie gewalt oder
sonstwas funktionen über meine post ab
hast du der backe was meinst du ein
problem was hast du noch wie geht's denn
hier geht's deiner leber wie das
interessiert mich da kein ja aber ich
hatte eigentlich aber das ist ja das ist
ja in dieser was ist das für niveau
aller freue mich immer über wir hier das
doch darüber reden weil hier die
deutsche ich komm ich bin richtig gut
drauf so schön wenn du richtig schön
drauf also voran die ps autos erkennt
wie den neuen z3 von bmw